[Musique]
mais je vois rien ça va trop gras ça va
aller ça va arriver là qu'arrive le
carton à gauche
encore là ya pas de carton
[Musique]
non rien de mal à faire
c'est ça ma vie selongey à des questions
regarder plus loin vous allez voir les
cartes aux arrêts mais super actuelle
ban et j'avais la tête qui tournait
seulement 30 secondes
puis mon immersion flash c'est la
première fois contre les femmes est la
première qui se rencontrent j'ai
vraiment dansera merci rossi mais
comment sa vie
voyais un mode fun lancer dans ce milieu
comme ça de la pauvreté parce que les
hommes et son entraîneur habile car je
m'étais même ce que tu es toi
c'est toi qui l'a choisie mou c'est
parce que malheureusement
salut et m'a trouvé autre chose
mais si j'ai trouvé un travail je
travaillais lacombe attend tellement
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à travailler et
découvrir la vie de ma collègue mais
voilà au bout de 30 minutes j'ai la tête
qui tourne et je dois m'arrêter avant de
partir je ne peux m'empêcher de prendre
tous hâte dans mes bras
cette femme est un véritable exemple
pour moi vers sainte est très courageux
mercier droit en tout cas des deux est
le meilleur
merci je sais que tu as des enfants et
tu te lèves et tu as du courage pour
venir travailler dette élevée et ça
c'est qui a rien de plus beau
franchement c'est extraordinaire on
parle le plus
à ce titre je pourrais pas faire ça tout
ça je voulais était hyper paternité
c'est hyper courage de ce que tu fais et
c'est comme perdre un proche
[Musique]
d'accord robineau souhaite
l'hiver touche en fait une femme comme
ça qui est fort et blessé un enfant qui
refuse à toute la journée
et
et au bout d'une demi heure si sam a
déjà soulevé pas réussi at il fait
recours âgées
tous
voilà